the Winter Olympics are presenting an
image of warmer ties between North and
South Korea athletes from both countries
marched under a unified flag and the
sister of North Korean leader Kim
jong-un became the first member of her
family to visit the South since the
Korean War
but many South Koreans say there's a
quote illusion of peace to appease the
North Holly Williams is in Seoul South
Korea Holly good morning good morning
there are some things here in South
Korea that most people agree on like
just how well Korean barbecue goes with
beer but when it comes to how to deal
with North Korea their closest neighbor
and worst enemy
they cannot agree Yim Kyung soon hits
the slopes outside Seoul every two weeks
carving up the powder
he's also 88 years old and still full of
life mr. Yim learned to ski in the 1940s
but then he had to stop he told us
because he signed up to fight in the
Korean War
it began in 1950 and killed 4 million
people by some estimates the Korean
Peninsula is now divided between a
communist north and a capitalist south
we need to reunify our country mr. Yim
told us we need to work together to
bring peace
the singers in this choir agree heal the
world they sing Michael Jackson's plea
for peace they're a mix of South Koreans
and defectors from North Korea making
perfect harmony but the store in
relations has also caused a backlash
these right-wing protestors say their
government is appeasing the north after
venting their feelings about North
Korea's dictator Kim jong-un the police
moved in emotions run high when your
nuclear capable enemy is just 35 miles
away and recent polls show around half
of young South Koreans don't support
reunification many of them say after 70
years of division the North is now a
foreign country when they wanted to talk
they shot missiles first this group said
reunification might be nice one day but
feared it would mean bankrolling the
poverty-stricken north and higher taxes
for them it is something that is
desirable but I don't think Korea is
ready to handle the drawbacks
it cost us tons and tons of money to
build in the country reunification may
be a distant dream or nightmare
depending on your perspective but a
summit meeting between the two Koreas
could happen this year and that would be
the first time that top leaders from the
two countries have met in more than a
decade Gayle
all right Holly we'll all be watching
thank you very much